the following content is provided under
a Creative Commons license your support
will help MIT OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational resources
for free
to make a donation or view additional
materials from hundreds of MIT courses
visit MIT opencourseware at ocw.mit.edu
we have this definition for the class
object I've I've created the in it for
you and here I'm giving itself which is
the first thing that you have to give it
and then two parameters W and D and for
for an instance of a car I'm going to
assign the data attribute named wheels
to whatever is passed in for W so notice
that they're not the same name and the
data attribute for doors is going to be
the value that's passed in for D okay
and also notice that inside the anit I
can do any other sort of initializations
that I'd like so it's not just assigning
variables from the parameters to local
to two variables for for my objects so
in this case I'm creating a new data
attribute named color and I'm going to
just create it to be an empty string
okay notice because I didn't even even
though I didn't pass in any color to my
to my object so the question says using
the class definition above which line
creates a new car object with four
wheels and two doors okay so this this
first one is not right because it's
trying to call the class with a variable
my car so for self which isn't quite
right so when you're creating a when
you're creating your object you have to
give it one less parameter than what you
have so here we're just going to have to
create it with the W and the D so we're
going to create this these variable this
variable my car and we're going to
assign it for for the number of wheels
and two for the number of doors and the
number of wheels is the first parameter
and the number of doors is the second
one so should be this one here car 4
comma 2 so that's this one perfect